ya know it's not so clear maybe so
that's why it would be much better
[Music]
no you cannot move the Knights we have
to play different anyway we have a show
to do there's a lot of activity these
things that play - office we have
tactics frenzy coming out which is being
better tested right now just try to tell
the day go to score of 2000 rating I'm
sure that can be happens but for those
haters who say that I'm not too great at
tactics they're certainly got some some
ammunition there anyway
as for upping our game we're adding to
our team and I'd like the opportunity to
introduce few of them first of all we
got Olga who's been working with play
minors for a few years already exactly
what are you doing these days
om I'm developing games for the apps and
content for the games so if someone is
struggling for example with tactics
frenzy for that matter you know who to
blame
very good we'll certainly will blame you
then we got a few young people let's
start with with our n I'm sure a lot of
our Norwegian audience and also our
international female audience know you
can you say a few words to introduce
yourself yeah I'm a formidable Junior
Champion and right now I'm just playing
chess full time and what are you looking
to do for our play - platforms I'm
looking forward to stream a bit for play
- and play some been through this really
so you I'm you have to up your your
trash talk I have to say gotta gotta be
a more snappy sure hull workers well we
will go then to
somebody who I think has some experience
streaming and trash-talking which is
Marshall Scott yeah then I streamed a
lot like two years ago my screen for
three or four months I did it every day
so I'm kind of used to a streaming thing
but news to say - so what is the best
quality you can bring as a streamer well
I think I'm known to be laid-back um I
like to sacrifice pieces do you prepare
for your games though sometimes
sometimes okay but you're you're a
natural talent you yeah they're good
what about you Sebastian do you have
natural talent or are you also kind of
lazy
well yeah I'm uh I'm known for being a
spontaneous and charismatic and if you
may say so yes exactly and yeah well my
chest isn't exactly the most impressive
thing but I believe I have other
important qualities but as far as I know
you have done quite a lot of YouTube
videos rights right I have YouTube
channel with 6000 subscribers and I
still make youtube videos on that
channel and what kind of videos are are
those that you make I make gaming videos
that are mostly for a small children but
they are very popular on my channel so
that's all I can say about that's all I
can say we're - we're trying to reach
all of the all of our possible audience
we I've been saying for many years that
we we should target all all ages so I
think that's that's wonderful
well then again we get to the master of
puppets' the hammer
some people are referring to you as a
bit of a husband what do you say to
counter those allegations I I don't
think they can be countered III thought
of this thing myself that if you can't
do teach if you can't teach cast and I
think
I'm around there I did play at some
point now I tried teaching a little bit
but I'm down to just doing commentary on
stuff and yeah I have to say personally
I enjoy or your commentary a lot so not
as much as your your play obviously but
you can't have everything so you're
you're the one who as I understand will
be mentoring the the younger kids yes
for sure and they need some mentoring
they need a somewhat older guys to tell
them what to do and I got that covered
that's that sounds great and we'll be
looking forward to seeing their results
in the future well that's all for us
here at the Play - office today we will
be back with lots more content from all
of these great people
[Music]